you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
cyclone seroja hits australia after
causing devastation in indonesia
we're looking at if climate change is to
blame for more extreme weather
it's back to beer gardens in england we
look at why your locally sourced burger
is
three times greener than one in south
america
and green houses the italian architect
tackling building emissions
by 3d printing homes out of clay
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions this show aims to take you to
the heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
now cyclone seroja has made landfall in
western australia causing damage to
homes and power supplies
such powerful cyclones are rare in
subtropical australia
the storm took an unusual path because
it interacted with another cyclone
odette
this phenomenon is known as the
fujihuara effect and it could become
more common
as climate change is expected to alter
weather patterns
before hitting the town of cal barrie in
australia the cyclone caused
far more damage when it struck indonesia
and east timor
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
prepare yourselves before we go into red
alert
[Music]
[Music]
so how likely is it that extreme and
unusual weather events are linked to
climate change
well joining me now is dr freddie otto
for the environmental change institute
at the university of
oxford dr freddie otto is it possible to
know if climate change
has had an impact on this cyclone
it is too early to say what the impact
of climate change
is on this cyclone but what we do know
is that because ocean temperatures are
now
higher in places where they they didn't
used to be
high enough for cyclones to form that we
do see an increase in cyclones in places
where they were very rare that doesn't
mean that every cyclone
is more likely or more extreme because
of climate change and we
don't see a general trend in that but we
do see them in places where people were
not used to cyclones
and extreme weather has always happened
so how do you attribute
a single event to climate change
extreme weather has always happened
indeed and every extreme weather event
has always
multiple causes but in the same way that
for example
after a volcanic eruption a big volcanic
eruption when you have lots of particles
in the high atmosphere that block
sunlight
you have an increased likelihood of cold
events
that come in the one or two years that
it takes for the particles
to wash out in the same way greenhouse
gases increase greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere
do change the intensity and frequency
of extreme weather events we see
particularly a strong
increase in intensity and frequency of
heat waves
we see fewer and less colder cold waves
and for all other types of extreme
events the changes are
very different from place to place in
the world so
in southern africa we see an increase in
droughts
in uh in northern europe we see an
increase in
extreme rainfall we also see an increase
actually
in extreme rainfall associated with
tropical cyclones
but because there are always multiple
effects playing together for most
complex weather events you really have
to look at the
at the local scale to know exactly what
role climate change is playing but we
are increasingly able to do that
and if global warming continues at its
current rate more generally what's going
to happen to the weather
so um if it's continuing at the current
rate
we will see even more devastating heat
waves people usually think about heat
waves oh it's
time to go to the beach but heat waves
are already even in the uk
the by far the most deadly extreme event
so last year alone
more than 250 uh 2500 people have been
killed
in in a heat wave and so globally we'll
see
much more of that we also see more
extreme rainfall events especially the
very localized events that have
a lot of rain in a very short time
leading to flash floods
and um for for other extremes it really
again
depends on where you are in the world so
droughts
also increase in the mediterranean and
parts of southern america
and uh when an uh
tropical cyclone is happening they are
more
devastating because of the increased
rainfall that climate change
brings with it dr freddie osso thank you
and you can hear more from dr freddie
otto on our climate cast podcast
and you can find that on apple spotify
or wherever you normally get your
podcast from
in today's other climate news now and a
new technology
could reduce carbon emissions from the
uk's aviation industry
by 60 million tonnes each year satavia
has developed software that re-routes
airplanes to prevent them from leaving
cloud trails
called contrails scientists believe
contrails are bad for the environment
because they trap heat
from the earth's atmosphere which warms
the air
john alumni and chris packham are
amongst the celebrities backing an
appeal
to save an ethiopian forest the charity
tree aid will give communities in matema
the tools and training to restore nearly
24 000 acres of woodland
the forest is particularly important as
frankincense is found there
which is used in essential oils around
the world
and ever wondered how your shopping
habits affect the environment
well mastercard is launching an online
calculator which lets you work out
the climate impact of what you buy the
calculator will also tell you the number
of
trees that are needed to offset your
purchase
now pop gardens and outdoor dining
reopen in england today and for many the
weeks of looking forward to a meal and a
pint at your local
are finally over so we thought we'd take
the opportunity to look at the climate
impact of a pub classic because
depending on
where you eat it seems not all burgers
are created equally
a cheeseburger chips and a pint of lager
is a pub classic so let's take a look at
the emissions produced if all the
ingredients are sourced
from the uk or the eu and that is a
total of
6.1 kilograms of carbon dioxide
equivalent now co2 equivalent means
the number of metric tons of co2
emissions with the same
global warming potential as one metric
ton
of another greenhouse gas now most of
that
6.1 kilos is the environmental impact of
beef and so let's compare that to a
similar meal
prepared in latin america and you get
three times
the emissions 19.8 kilograms
of co2 equivalent and again the majority
of that
is down to the beef but it's much higher
and that's because developing countries
have to transform
land to have space to graze cattle and
grow
crops meaning an increase in
deforestation and pollution
and worldwide three-quarters of
greenhouse gas emissions from the food
system
are from developing countries so let's
speak then to dr tara garnett from the
university of oxford about this
so dr tara garnett why does the meat
industry
produce emissions like this well there
are three main
sources of emissions from from the meat
industry um the first
is what you might call direct admission
so in the case of
beef that's methane which uh animals
burp out
and it is a very potent greenhouse gas
as you mentioned
the second source is land use change and
that can be either direct or indirect so
when it comes to direct we're talking
cattle grazing but there's also the
hidden
land use change impact um of feeding
animals
and that's pigs and poultry as well as
beef things like
soy and maize and so forth where forests
are cleared
and land is plowed up and that also
generates
carbon dioxide emissions and so that
links to the third point
it's it's the feed that they that they
eat that has an
impact on emissions and when you look at
this you find that
all meat and all animal products has
disproportionately high
environmental impacts well above
plant-based foods on average
and beef tends to rank um highest but it
does depend on
where you're sourcing your beef from um
when it comes to latin america
and brazil specifically um it is worth
remembering that
we live in an interconnected world
and those that beef is also being
produced for
export so a lot of the time we think
that our emissions don't look that high
but we're actually
um importing somebody else's problem or
rather we're exporting our problems to
to them and we don't want to put people
off their pub grub that they've been
looking forward to
for months but if they did want an
eco-friendly alternative what should
they do
um well i don't think there really is an
eco-friendly alternative
all beef generates and indeed all meat
generates high environmental impacts
i would say if you're going if you're
lucky enough to get into a pub today
enjoy your food enjoy your pint enjoy
your beef burger but
but remember that meat um that the best
way to reduce your climate impact
is actually to reduce just eat
less of it eat less of it and less often
and you know meat used to be a
celebration food is what you'd save up
for it was a sunday dinner
um and i think there's a role for meat
in our diets but
we need to we need to remember its value
and that means
um you know eating it for celebration
such as today
but shifting more to eating maybe a
veggie burger or other
plant-based foods dr tara garnett thank
you
and if you want to understand more about
what terms like co2 equivalent mean just
head to our website skynews.com
climate for our a to z glossary
now then let's take a quick look at our
data dashboard i want to show you
this number here which shows you how
much our planet is warming
right now because of human activity and
as you can see it's ticking
up every second now in the 2015 paris
agreement 196 countries around the world
agreed to work towards keeping global
warming below
2 degrees ideally at 1.5 degrees in
order to avoid the worst
impacts of climate change and below it
you can see
this clock here which is counting down
second by second
as we head towards that 1.5 degrees of
warming
now emissions from the building sector
reached their highest ever level in 2019
and manufacturing traditional materials
is particularly energy intensive cement
produces approximately eight percent of
the global total
of co2 a greater share than any country
other than china or the us
so italian architect mario cuccinella
wanted to do his bit
to try to come up with a solution his
answer
3d printing houses made entirely from
raw earth
buildings in the next 50 years will have
a very big impact on the environment the
paradox
of the next year will be in one side we
want to reduce emission
to zero the emission of co2 and on the
other side we need to build billions of
square meters
[Music]
tecla is the first experiment of a house
building in clay through the wasp
company so we we matching the idea of an
old material we will mix with the new
technology
3d printing and creating a house in clay
maybe the future is also to look our
path
and discovery the knowledge we are lost
in the last 250 years
maybe the next cities where we would
like to be
the smart city green city zero to a
mission city is a
city in clay but mixing digital
and old material
well that's it from us for now coming up
on the daily climate show
tomorrow the clever solution giving
single-use ppe
waste a new lease of life we've got
around
3 000 faulty single-use face masks here
what happens is they go inside the
machine
at the hospital for around an hour what
comes out is this 20 kilogram block of
plastic
that's at the same time tomorrow here on
sky news see you then
you